dico solo una cosa enrico inquadra
questo vuol dire che è fatta è troppo
sicuro di sé ciao ragazzi ben tornati
alla nona puntata di cucina buttata oggi
faremo un qualcosa che abbiamo provato a
fare tantissimi tantissimi mesi fa si
parla quasi di anni sto parlando della
nutella fatta in casa in passato abbiamo
seguito un meme per riuscire a
realizzarle secondo me alla fine non è
che avevo proprio reso giustizia alla
ricetta si abbiamo riso abbiamo
scherzato però di base la domanda è
rimasta la stessa esiste un modo per
fare la nutella fatta in casa per chi
non la conoscesse questa qui è inutile
per fare questa ricetta ci siamo
ispirati alla ricetta che propone il caf
time che ha creato effettivamente una
nota e l'ha fatta in casa qual è il bug
di questo ragazzo che è molto simpatico
e che sembra aver creato un qualcosa di
estremamente simile nel modello
originale almeno visivamente perché non
ci dice anima mente le dosi quindi avere
un pochino come ha fatto lui alla cazzo
di cane rapine video di quel ragazzo di
veder passeggiare la bella alla ragazza
è palesemente un'opera di recitazione
definzione se riusciremo a fingere anche
noi il rito per fare la nutella avremmo
bisogno di una caterva di nocciole
zucchero a velo cacao in polvere show
culla dei new d'arachidi nu brizzi che
il diesel è un barattolo da farcire lui
riscalda il forno a 350 gradi fahrenheit
che sarebbe i nostri 180 celsius quindi
parto subito
per prima cosa aggiungiamo un mezzo
pound che sarebbero più o meno 225 e 226
grammi di noci nocciole che luci se non
ci sono queste nemmeno cervelli però
dico lo facciano bene al cervello ovvero
riceventi tutta la frutta che assomiglia
a una parte del corpo fa bene a quella
parte del coro tipo le noci grado non
c'è più banale è una formina l'ha fatta
fixed l'attuale legge rivede una
somiglianza dire si gommi ci siamo
infiliamo per 10 15 minuti quindi le
faremo 12 perché 10 bar a 15 minuti che
faccio di testa mia
nel frattempo andiamo in vantaggio che
andava a tagliare nero in vantaggio nel
frattempo ci avvantaggiano e tagliamo il
cioccolato lui dice che sono due once se
non sbaglio in questo video dice mezzo
pound una tazza 5 cucchiai once cioè
alle dei disagi gli americani con queste
cazzo dici così che un quadrato ne
accetto perché questi sono fatti apposta
grammatici sono due non ci sono fatti
apposta privati se non avete una
bilancia e b dice le conce in g
sarebbero 36 e mezzo mi metto a questo
punto a minimizzarlo superfino così fa
molte domande da parte di tutti ma che
cazzo ci mettete sette anni miss era
anzitutto a parlare al singolare perché
non sai l'abilità dei cuochi che ci
seguono anche se lo sa che io ho
incominciato odiare il fatto che si
parli al plurale ragazzi chi vorrà
incomincia a dire e in sappi che un
casino non ti troverai bene anche perché
funziona questa cosa quante persone
cento
parliamoci chiaro ci sarà singolare
manco te quando rimonti neve di
chiaramente guarda come un [ __ ]
così veramente ok ragazzi ho fatto un
ottimo ottimo lavoro sono veramente
delle spoglie perché rete un quarto
d'ora tagliamo cubi
non può essere un quarto d'ora se sono
dodici minuti quelli che abbiamo messo
la matematica per te un'opinione mancano
vedere ci ho messo nove minuti ancora
meno dello stile di guglielmo da 1 a
vacca vacca e top quindi come va
benissimo ma che si complimenta un altro
complimenti sapete qual è iscrivervi a
questo canale attivare a comprare le
notifiche ecco la campanella invece del
talent e la prendiamo enrico sotto al
sole una presina che buon odore un altro
po i dodici comuni perché la pellicina
che sta sopra le noccioline e
distinguere e nocciole noccioline
siccome sono i fusti lingle e gli
stronzi alle persone per bene le
nocciole devono praticamente avere la
pelle sono che quasi un pochino si alza
che seccano che pare buttando banale o
no dove con tale ringrazia ma scusami
fate le cose appello ha detto ma tu come
fai la voce a chi non sa cucinare
persone prendete a questo punto uno
strofinaccio utilizzerò una busta si è
sciolto sono un [ __ ] no è caduto del
cioccolato ci sono feriti ma mia stima
ma non certo perché poi tanto
l'asciugamano la vita mia
se però devo dire la ragazza le nocciole
sono come le palline base cioè le lanci
e comunque si stanno scambiando ottimo
portatemi dyson subito bravo con questo
occhio e coppa ereditato da non ha il
potere di superare vuoto gran cagata per
qualcuna si è fatta un'altra no abbiamo
di più
[Musica]
insisti sciistici a prendere le nocciole
relais infilo all'interno di un mixer e
frullate quello che c'è da casa è
attenuta posto abbiamo già fallito
perché tu sei team sarà un fallimento
infatti si sono scusate la tecnica si
sono bruciate non perfettamente
masticasse c'erano pure le dosi in
realtà voi dovete sapere questa cosa
gianmarco e ha detto ha spesso capito
selezione delle ricette il problema è
che lui anche quelli che poi dal video
va a prendere ingredienti e lui stesso
traduce rischi per piante che non è che
vengono e mi dicano che dice vorrei dire
una cosa ma purtroppo è una ricetta che
non dice assolutamente le dosi
ok va bene però facciamo la nutella figo
si stimava lincoln e dice mi sono
arrabbiato perché gli americani una
tazza un cucchiaio mezza oncia nella
suggerita graziata graziana che ci
spiega come vivere pof pur di vedere le
dico sì ma barzelletta come sempre se
siete interessati vi lasciamo in
descrizione il link affiliato per
acquistare le tasse i cucchiai misurini
americani del cazzo
nel frattempo però noi iniziamo a
toccare le nostre nocciole sesso si è
granuloso credevo proprio riuscire a
ottenere una crema
basta ragazzi vedete questo qui è già di
per sé una crema spalmabile alla
nocciola aggiungiamo una tazza di
zucchero a velo nel campo poi sullo
spargimento quanto sul tagliere non
c'hanno tu comunque non so anche periodo
della tua vita tu stia vivendo ma non è
buono zucchero a velo 5 cucchiai di
cacao in polvere com ha creato un
giramento già zuccherato 234 ma che
davvero tua cazzo gianmarco infatti
tutte giuste le redine ma non sapeva
nemmeno quali fossero un pizzico di
cumulo che per cumulo intendo sale
chiudiamo e tentiamo di nuovo due
cucchiai di olio di arachidi che
qualcuno non è riuscito e infine ragazzi
il nostro cioccolato le due once che
erano i nostri 35 vado adesso abbiamo
finito e nutella siamo
in attività ci siamo hai visto della
nutella dentro ragazza ha l'odore è
inebriante io ho visto qualcosa si vede
che sei soddisfatto no dico solo una
cosa enrico inquadra questo vuol dire
che è fatta è troppo sicuro di sé
[Musica]
ci credo
alcun nome di che dopo un bel barattolo
dimensioni giuste
no però lo voglio fare
no no no campo di creato assurdo
[Musica]
la parola adesso è ancora estremamente
liquida un pochino come la nutella
io propongo di chiudere e la lasciamo un
secondo accettarsi in un ambiente fresco
fresco frigorifero fiori però la polizia
eccoci qui l'apicoltura casentinese e
adesso e nettare si presenta sempre un
pò liquidino vediamo si presenta poeta
un discorso di consistenze del
cioccolato che le ha dato questa
cremosità improvvisamente assaggerò nel
metodo più puro di tutti sono confuso
stai dicendo che quella biondina il
video è una bugiarda è una bugiarda ma
ti invito ad assaporarla
capisci cosa intendo è una buona crema
di nocciole diverse cose differenti
dalla modella razzano festeggiare il
sapore buono va bene va bene le maniere
ma è possibile ma [ __ ] guarda
anche tu non è assaggiato quella che
abbiamo fatto schifo quell'orrore vero
pericolo e tu momento così sembra spagna
maroni così immangiabile grazie rigo
allora abbiamo riso esatto è buono
chiaramente però non è una modella
allora è molto grumosa non è nutella se
dovessi giudicare il piatto a seconda di
parametri di bontà dico ok promosso
parametri di somiglianza alla modella ha
bocciato la linea che bisogna andare in
fondo
allora siamo parte positiva parte
negativa la parte negativa la parte
negativa sono grazia neri coke è come se
avessero bevuto un bicchiere di merda
via poi mara beta lettera come me qual è
il tuo parere per me è buonissima la
consistenza un po la prega perché
bollino bollino è vero pro da grande
professionista demaniale tenutella
promossi ma quanto si avvicina secondo
te questa fa più di olio però forse con
meno olio si potrebbe avvicinare ancora
di più comunque promossa per quanto mi
riguarda ed è con questa grande verità
fatto il mio stesso commento silenzio
ilaria incamerati nella vergogna di
ragazzi noi approviamo il sapore
disapproviamo la somiglianza ci vediamo
giovedì con un nuovo video grazie per
essere rimasti fino a qui ciao
[Musica]